I don't tell this story a lot because I
don't get it we I was in uh fourth grade
out of nowhere my mother turns to me and
goes you're not going to school tomorrow
so I go but we're going on a field trip
we're going to little Vietnam I really
want to go and she goes when do you
leave I go first thing in the morning
she goes when do you come back I go 3:00
she goes you're not in the school at all
I go no we get dropped off we get on the
bus we come back at the end of the day
she thinks for a long time she goes you
can go to school the next day there's a
true story May 20th 1988 a woman walked
into the school wearing a robe and
nothing underneath the room was empty
she walked through walked down the hall
walked into another room shot Seven kids
killed one of them true
story to this day my mom cannot explain
why she didn't want me to go to school
when I've talked to her to this day and
I've brought it up to her a lot she goes
I don't know Jake I just I had a feeling
in my gut kid goes to school you're
never going to see him again mom's
awesome right but what is that oh you